if I've done something to you just tell  me what I've done here  I just don't like you no more  have you been around have you been  rowing  I've been wrong that does look like  we're wrong  she'll stop being friends with a fella  he's Donald Trump but he's always been  done  maybe this whole thing has just been  above can't you just stand enough for  yourself  what did you come here for I just came  to kick your door and give you a  slagging  me a sin now with the father no but it's  not very nice either isn't  what I've decided to do is this I have a  set of shears at home and each time you  bother me I'll take one of my fingers  off with them starting from now but sure  straight for me you know  it's about one boring man leaving  another man alone  man you're all  right let's call it quits  call it quits  we call it the start